good morning John I am so sorry to hear
about your back I hope that you are
feeling better it sounds terrible I did
a bunch of research on herniated discs
because that's kind of my thing I
figured I'd tell you what I learned
because it's fascinating and it seems
like maybe the reason that humans so
often have bad backs stretches all the
way back to the Advent of bipedalism
we'll get there but first we need to
talk about your back so we're
vertebrates which is great we have a
spinal column that's protected by bone
but you still want to be able to like
Bend and twist and stuff because
otherwise you can't do Tick-Tock dances
so the vertebrates solution to this
problem is lots of individual vertebra
with these little things in between them
that are really hard but kind of squishy
at the same time discs they're called
intervertebral discs not intervertebral
intervertebral because they want people
to look stupid it's basically a very
firm but squishy ring and inside of the
ring is contained a gel now a bunch of
things can happen to that little disc to
make it wear out like you could just get
older that that's part of it injury also
a big one but also just putting a load
on it not directly where it's aligned
usually so if you're standing up like
it's it's pretty much like where the
weight is supposed to be but if you're
sitting down especially if you're like
slouching and your your butt's a little
forward that can put some extra pressure
on those lower back intervertebral discs
and then there's also genetic stuff like
the kinds of collagen proteins you make
in the shape of your spine and vertebral
all matter and if that hard squishy disc
breaks down enough eventually the gel
can leak out from inside of it and
that's a herniated disc and it's painful
and sounds very bad all this is to say
you and I have very similar genetics and
similar Lifestyles so now I'm scared uh
and I'll be watching not for the warning
signs but here's the thing chimpanzees
gorillas orangutans our three closest
relatives none of them have this happen
to them so the obvious question to ask
is why what's different and there's two
main hypotheses the first one is that
like chimpanzees do chimpanzee stuff
like their bodies are evolved for the
lifestyle that they live and at first
this hypothesis was looking pretty good
because people who lived a more
hunter-gatherer lifestyle had less
reported back pain but the more we
looked into that the more it seemed like
it was actually the the reported part of
reported back pain not the back pain
part that was rare people were just
living through their pain and indeed we
have now seen lots of evidence of
ruptured discs in the human fossil
record so it seems like it's been a
thing the whole time which is not to say
that your lifestyle does not affect
whether or not you might get a ruptured
disc it absolutely does the other
hypothesis is that there's just
something not great about human backs
we're seven million years into the shift
to bipedalism but it is a relatively
large shift like it's a totally
different thing to have all your body
weight stacked on the vertebral column
rather than sort of hanging off of it
like it would for a dog or even a
chimpanzee to some extent but how do you
test for this well there's some
scientists who looked at a bunch of
human vertebra that had evidence or not
evidence of having hemorrhaged discs and
the ones that had Hemorrhage discs were
much more likely to look more similar to
chimpanzee vertebra so it seems like
people who have vertebra with similar
morphology and characteristics to
chimpanzees are more likely to get
ruptured discs almost as if their spines
are more ancestral now this is why and
it was a pretty small study and it only
looked at Europeans so you can't take
that much from it but they actually did
a follow-up study with 3D scans and one
of the authors said this and I quote the
humans that have intervertebral disc
herniations tend to have a shape that is
statistically indistinguishable from
chimpanzee vertebrae so John it may be
that your vertebra shape is
statistically indistinguishable from
that of a chimpanzee he might think okay
there was plenty of time to evolve our
way out of chimpanzee vertebra but then
in a separate paper some of those
researchers found that you could
actually swing too far toward like
optimize for bipedalism and you get a
separate Condition it's called
spondylolysis and it causes stress
fractures in the spine so that's also
bad so maybe we are not yet optimized
for bipedalism or maybe bipedalism is
just really difficult to optimize for in
our sort of body type like kangaroo seem
to have it figured out also all birds
are bipedal and they seem like they're
doing fantastic anyway John I'm sure
that this didn't help with your pain at
all but it's pretty much all I know how
to do in a situation like this I'll see
you on Tuesday